oh regardez mademoiselle inconnue qui appelle encore
et qu'est-ce qui vous ferait penser que l'
inconnu ne va pas je devine juste
bonjour ce transporteur vous avez le
beau costume belle voiture
et la belle fille devant travailler
pour un groupe de belles
femmes intelligentes très nouveau  situation du
transporteur ne gâchez pas ça, elles sont
absolument magnifiques ces femmes sont un
vrai match pour un ami maintenant conduisez
nous jouons des femmes vraiment très dures
vous devez devenir ces guerriers que vous
savez mettre l'équipement dessus c'est chercher
la vengeance ils vont  à travers beaucoup de
looks différents dans le film, vous savez
Sydney,
ils ont la perruque blonde, elle est incroyable à
quel point cela transforme leur relation,
ils ont vraiment compliqué, ils
se sont évidemment attirés l'un vers l'autre, mais
c'est plus le jeu, surtout pour Anna,
peut-être que nous travaillerons  ensemble à nouveau à l'
avenir ce n'est pas aller de l'avant
les filles étaient super elles étaient très amusantes
et elles étaient vraiment rentrées à la maison je veux
faire de l'action viens sur
mon  sentiments exactement nous nous sommes beaucoup
amusés nous nous sommes vraiment amusés j'ai hâte que
tout le monde voie